you've made a career spanning up to two
bullies to really sticking with what you
believe when you you right now I mean
you're constantly whining you guys got a
new project is that you're working on
through I mean how how does that do you
think about that when you're thinking
like how am I going to get this project
out there because it seems the
industry's changed so much in the last
20 30 years well yes it is a terrific
point I'd go right ten bowls I don't
like Marvel Comics kind of stuff you
know then whim and what I write the in
you know the movie this course is to be
made thanks to this man is Rover sitting
there is so as I wrote a piece about my
Dara my dad was he was the great
inspiration of my life he was on very
anomalous and the my mom was a
schizophrenic so it was very difficult
he was the only hit up related to plan
and he always encouraged me and he was
always there whenever I needed him and
he went out of his way to inspire okay
no it was just a an amazing relationship
when I was 48 years old being the
Justice Department um put him on
earrings for having committed war crimes
and up one of the things that my father
always said to me was touch people only
minor character not about their religion
not about their beliefs but only by
their character and now they behave and
here's a man and what we said to me oh
he said these things to me in there were
these charges in and I was ribbon you
know my apply what happened in my
relationship with him was never the same
and I'm written about
so my books but then I wrote a script
called pleasant what that my friend that
she stole ready it said we have to make
this as a movie and it will then we're
going to now I grant you that this is a
million miles away from shoulder smell
very happy that it's gonna make
you